not too long ago a wine steward I
patronize on festive occasions suggested
what he described as a saucy little
grape he said its domestic but it's good
to present the awards for art direction
here is a young man who was domestic and
really good he copped his Oscar for his
brilliant choreography in an American in
Paris my old shipmate from the SS MGM
mr. Gene Kelly
in motion pictures the director supplies
the motion and the art director supplies
the picture he designs the sets he
adapts the location sites to suit the
needs of the script he is an architect
an engineer a draftsman the color expert
an artist and a businessman rolled into
one instant magician tonight those
nominated for best achievement in art
direction for black and white production
are days of wine and roses art direction
Joseph Wright set decoration George
James Hopkins the longest day art
direction Ted Hayworth Leon barsac and
Vincent kurta set decoration Gabrielle
they shear the period of adjustment
art direction George W Davis and Edward
Carfagna set decoration Henry Grace and
dick pepper me the pitch in the took
rome art direction al pereira roland
anderson set decoration Sam comer and
Frank are McKelvey To Kill a Mockingbird
art direction Alexander Golitsyn and
Henry Bumstead set decoration Oliver
Emmett and now the envelope please and
the winners are Alexander galitsin and
henry Bumstead for the kill a
mockingbird
from my other associates and the
craftsmen that worked with us in
Hollywood thank you very much thank you
very much thanks everyone
and now the nominees for best
achievement in art direction for a color
production are Lawrence of Arabia art
direction John box and John Stoll set
decoration by Dario Simoni Meredith
Willson's The Music Man art direction by
Paul Gross set decoration by George
James Hopkins and mutiny on the bounty
art direction by George W Davis and Jay
Macmillan Johnson set decoration by
Henry grace and Hugh hunt that touch of
mink art direction by Alexander glitzen
and Robert Klatte worthy and set
decoration by George Milo the wonderful
world of the Brothers Grimm art
decoration art direction by George W
Davis and Edward Fania set decoration on
Henry Grace and dick Beverly and now the
colouring point and the winners are John
box and John Stoll for Lawrence of
Arabia Arabia was set decoration
darío a similar
excepting for John box John Stoll and
Dario Simoni and Jeffries and Bob
sterling
I have three of these can you handle two
I think so this is indeed a joyous night
for everyone connected with Lawrence of
Arabia and it's a great honor for us to
be able to accept these awards from mr.
boxer mr. stone thank you so much